hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
bruh back on apex legends again and
today we're gonna be doing a to list of
all two legends with an apex legends as
of right now within a couple days this
is gonna be based off of their ability
to fight and help and a team since FX
Legends is a team based battle royale
game which is the reason why you can
only play in a group of people I not
through solo if you have a different
opinion of mine then let me know in the
comments below with the description of
why you think that way I'm curious to
know everyone's thoughts and remember
these are just my opinions like I said
if you disagree let me know and is there
also gonna be some of my day 1
impressions of how the characters have
been playing you know I even though it's
been out for maybe a couple days or so
if there is a significant patch that
does change the flow of the game I'll
definitely be down to make another tier
list of how they play maybe if they had
solo I'll maybe make a solo tier list or
stuff like that so I mean on the
comments below if you guys want to see
that as well with that let's get started
with the list now I also forgot to
mention that we're also gonna be
starting from the bottom and going to
the top and at our number 8 spot at the
bottom is going to be caustic or
Alexander Knox
every character is solid and apex
legends respawn did a really good job
with that each character has one thing
that they're good at then another and
that's the one reason I like these
characters because they're not actually
garbage but some of them just have a
little bit less of an ability to help
the team than others but the reason I
put caustic and last is because of his
abilities and small situations his
passive is that he can see through the
gas which is pretty cool his tactical
allows him to place gas traps where has
also codes a huge area in gasps now
caustic excels and flushing out targets
from buildings and around cover
especially in buildings my only issue
which is why he's at the bottom is that
the NOx cast is very small damage maybe
maybe far I think around for damage or
so from what I've seen and I'm also
disappointed that his teammates cannot
see through the gas as well I understand
that that's his passive and he should
keep that but at least one of these
abilities like as all or as tactical
should have that type of capability as
well for the teammates this would help
tremendously and not made teammates be
useless when they're in the gas and Waka
blindly into the gas just like the
opponents are and no one knows what's
going on but you which is gonna really
help the fight go one way or the other
and not be a full dominant force for
your side number seven I have Wraith and
this might disappoint a lot of people
and I really do like her abilities for
the most part but it doesn't really suit
the team as much yeah her rift is a
really good ability being able to move
around the map dipper on enemy fire if
there's someone on the other side of a
bridge you can go cloak pop the rift and
go across and then have
teammates across the lot getting shot
that's very good as well but my main
issue with this is that the team can
also chase you through those portals
possibly setting you up for an ambush or
killed especially if your team is very
low on health and the enemy team is
pounding you with bullets and can walk
right through and be right next to you
and it's still game over which is the
one problem I do not like about her rift
and the chasing the storm is a pretty
nice idea having your teammates go
through the portal and not take damage
and also cross bigger platforms but if
your neck and neck with your teammates
and you're running at the same speed as
them why what's the point in that they
should just keep walking instead of
waiting and taking possibly even more
damage from it if they if they walk and
just completely disregard the rift maybe
that can actually give them less damage
taken so that can help her because she
gets a speed boost from that but it
really doesn't help the teammates as
much but I will admit her passive is
very useful for letting me know if
incoming enemies so I'll definitely give
her that number 6 we have Mirage the
cocky show-off I know I've actually had
a lot of fun playing it as him and I
have to admit he's a pretty good pick
but he's not the greatest pick in the
game very similar to Wraith his
abilities helped himself more than the
team his passive is awesome for not
being able to be seen for a bit and
possibly escape when he's down his
tactical and ultimate really only help
himself the only reason he is higher is
because of that decoy throwing a decoy
out can attract enemy fire telling you
which way they're coming from so that's
why he is sixth because of that ability
which in my experience is actually
helped a lot and got me a win a couple
times number five we have Pathfinder and
may I say people sleep on Pathfinder a
whole lot he's one of the most
underrated legends I think in this
entire game he has such great abilities
to help the team his passive can show
the next circle which can help plan and
where you want to go and explore
throughout the map they are also pretty
easy to find since they're always gonna
be marked on your map so you can
actually if you do have a Pathfinder on
your team you could pick a spot with one
of those beacons in it and get the next
circle instantly the tactical grapple is
more suited for himself but there is a
little nifty trick where if you look at
the object and grapple to it and then
look left or right with the joystick or
your mouse you can actually swing around
the object and gain lots of momentum
which can help save a teammate or
initiate a quick ambush his all charges
the fast in the game I believe which
allows for lots of uses in and can help
you and the teammates beat the circle a
lot more effective and Wraith and can
help you reach those hard-to-reach spots
a lot more for number 4 we got the big
Samoan man Gibraltar I'm actually not
even sure if he's Samoan
but to me he feels like the male
Banglore but with some obvious Tiff's
his dome shield can cover teammates and
provide easy revives and some time to
heal and shield up his gun show can
provide support for you and possibly a
teammate depending on how both you were
positioned and the ultimate does some
good damage and stun the opponents
making for a quick wipe of a squad his
damage from the out comes out almost
instantly which is nice to also catch
the people before they run inside so
that's why I picked Gibraltar at forth
number 3 is Bangalore and I actually
like her a lot more than Gibraltar which
is why she's put up a lot higher her
passive is useful for running away and
could potentially be used as a scouting
technique to go forward check up those
enemies and quickly rush back without
getting swamped with enemies her
tactical is also a pretty good option
somewhere to gibraltars it can save the
teammates from death provide easy heals
shields and revive times and most
importantly which is why she's ranked
higher than Gibraltar she has combo
potential using smoke and popping the OU
beast hunter which is blood hounds
ultimate allows him to see the entire
team in red while no one sees him
allowing for a quick easy team wipe or
at least the surprise jump on a team her
all is very similar to gibraltars but I
prefer hers a lot more to gibraltars bit
and that's why she excels a lot more
using this in an open field can flush
out opposing enemies out of cover
allowing for easy picks if you're at the
end of the game with not much room
because of the circle it's game over a
quick little story my team was fighting
the last team at the end of the game at
one of our matches all of us were down
except me but my teammate through the
Bangalore ultimate right before he went
down and destroyed the entire team since
the circle was only outside along for a
quick easy win because there was no
cover above them and they couldn't move
next up his bloodhound and he's number 2
on our list his passive is one of the
most helpful in the game I like to see
the footprints and tracking of enemies
can help prevent ambushes and
unawareness letting you know a fight may
start soon Ravens will also appear when
tracks are around allowing that for that
to help as well his tactical marks
enemies for your entire team so you know
where the team is and knowing how you
should handle the situation it all
doesn't really help the team as much but
if you use the pink system it can help a
lot more and also another hidden tip is
that apparently with large sniper sites
you can also look for tracks and finding
footprints and stuff like that using
those sites now I have actually I
actually haven't tried this out myself
but if this is actually confirmed baby
true and this is definitely an even
better reason why blood hunt is second
on the list
and lastly in first place is lifeline
you guys already know this was coming
lifeline is an absolute necessity in a
team every ability is useful to the team
that she has her passive shields her to
help save an easy revive her tactical
heals people for a considerable amount
of health and she can heal multiple
people at the same time only issue
though is that her drone can heal enemy
opponents as well I've experienced this
a couple days ago it's not great but
it's usually it's pretty situational and
her ultimate is like a Supply Drop but
only defensive things like armor shield
health etc so a super useful character
to have one playing but that guy is
gonna be the end of the bait say I hope
you guys did enjoy a quick recap we have
lifeline in first bloodhound in second
Bangalore and third Gibraltar and fourth
Pathfinder in fifth place Mirage in
sixth Rathod seventh and caustic at
eighth at the bottom like I said before
if you guys have a different opinion
than mine cuz there's most likely going
to have different opinions most of you
guys have probably played a different
character more than I have for example I
know there's a ton of people out there
that I probably played caustic a lot
more than I have so if you have some
interesting tips that you want to share
and why you think caustics may be at the
top or lifeline should be at the bottom
or anything like that any type of
opinion that you guys have I'd love to
know in the comments below
definitely start a discussion I'd love
to hear thoughts and why you think that
way what that guys like the V if you do
enjoy subscriber for new I've been
covering a lot of Apex recently I would
love in the game I'm assuming you guys
have too if you've clicked on this video
and I'm most likely gonna be covering
the news in the updates of the game so
if everyone can be up-to-date on what's
happening within the world of apex as
well so maybe some game playing guides
here and there but we'll have to see as
the game progresses and gets more
updates in the future my two most recent
videos will be on screen if you guys do
want to check that out with that guys
hope ever-greater day I thank you for
watching the video I mean your thoughts
on the tools in the comments below
peace out enjoy the rest of your day
[Music]